hi there steve kaufman here
another sunny morning in palm springs
i want to talk today about many stories
as a learning tool
remember if you enjoy these videos about
language learning please subscribe so
what are many stories many stories are
essentially what piotr
created over at
realpolis.pl stories which i used to
learn polish so they're not exactly
graded readers which is also a useful
sort of step towards authentic content
many stories are short you know five
eight ten line
stories
typically about a person doing something
in their daily life
the stories typically consist of three
parts
a description of
you know george gets up and reads the
newspaper
then george pours himself a cup of
coffee
simple stories like that and then the
second story mini story is the same
story
told by george i get up in the morning
so we have a repetition of the
vocabulary and then the third section
consists of questions did george get up
in the morning and of course
what's very good about what pyotr did
was he gives you the answer so you don't
have to rack your brain he says george
got up in the morning did george get up
in the morning
yes he got up in the morning or
did george sleep in
no george get up in the morning did
george sleep in no he didn't he got up
in the morning so
those are the three parts now you can
vary the formula somewhat uh and this is
what we have done
for these many stories that with
pyotr's permission we are creating in
english so that initially the in the
first we're going to do 100 of these the
first 20
the second section is a different person
so instead of she did this and this i do
this and this
then we start to introduce
different kinds of second stories where
we introduce we have the first story in
one tense and the second story in
another tense and again followed by
questions and as we progress we
introduce more and more concepts like
wish hope if art should
um
different aspects of the language and we
try as much as possible to bunch them
into different sections so that people
can go there not only when they're
learning the language but also to go and
practice some of the basic concepts and
and structures which continue to cause
trouble
now here's the pitch
i have had these translated into greek
for my own purposes and i'm studying
them on link
i love them i think it's very effective
um
i think it'd be it would be wonderful to
translate these into
many languages not only the languages
that we have at link of course we would
use them at link
for those languages that we're doing at
link but also other languages we don't
have farsi at link we don't have tagalog
we don't have indonesia
how many people out there
would be prepared to help out
to translate these stories
into other languages of course
immediate interest would be the stories
that we haven't linked
at least the languages we have at length
french chinese whatever arabic um so on
but also other languages and then we
make this available to people who are
learning languages whether they're doing
in that link or not
so we need translations and we need
recordings now the recording has to be
of a fairly good quality so does the
translation also the translation has to
be localized so if the english story
talks about mary and sam
then the spanish version has to talk
about i don't know consuelo and jorge
you can't and and then if there are
things that culturally don't fit they
have to be changed
also
while the some of the basic concepts
wish hope if ought to might they
translate into all different languages
but there will be specific language
issues in
certain languages and so we may have to
develop specific stories
for those issues
but always we want them translated into
all languages because of course at link
and elsewhere you know the idea that you
have a translation in your own language
is always helpful so that if you're
going through the story and you look up
the words and you've got the words and
you still can't make sense of it then at
least you can look at the translation of
that story so
long story short i would be interested
in knowing if there are people out there
who would be willing to get involved in
this project to develop these 100 mini
stories in as many languages as possible
uh to help the language learning world
of course we will use those
these stories at link
for those languages that we offer
but the stories themselves would be
public domain including the audio in
fact all of the audio and
text
lessons at link are available for free
download so it's only then people who
appreciate or value the functionality
that we offer link that would then
join link to study these stories but
other people can study them however they
want
so please let me know
and thank you for listening and how to
let me know
just email me
all right steve at link.com just email
me all right thanks for listening bye
for now
[Music]
you